ex-girlfriend's family thought i wanted
to [ __ ] my cousin yeah i think
i think everybody bro it's the way you
[ __ ] phrased it yeah that's bad man
that's really bad that's that's a rough
place to be it's like yeah well you're
when you're in a relationship you
shouldn't compare your relationship to
other people's relationships in the
first place that's the first fallacy
right
the second definitely don't compare it
to a relationship
with a family member also yeah and
that's that at any
next topic at any time in any moment not
even
not even just in a relationship but
amongst friends at work
never should [ __ ] your cousins and
family ever be a thing that you
talk about in five four
three two one hola everybody como estas
today's podcast is only going to be in
spanish uh patrick would you please
start us off
hola bienvenidos
why are you selling those used cars bro
you got to get amped in spanish man you
got to get amped you have to be
expressive on a genius brain
podcast nicolas
people always get shocked that you're
that you're mexican people will never
[ __ ] expect i want to believe it dude
sometimes i forget when i start speaking
spanish i'm like oh yeah i'm mexican
that's [ __ ] right his middle name is
tomas
tomas my name is patrick thomas riley
patrick
there's no h and there's a little accent
over there
i'm actually mostly mexican because my
dad was like irish italian my mom's just
full on mexican
oh [ __ ] yeah but the white jeans
they prominently took over dude yeah i
don't know what happened but uh they
just kicked in
on my face you're pretty fluent in it
though right yeah yeah
yeah i mean i grew up speaking it he can
hang with the best of them
yeah i mean tip is like oh patrick
spanish is actually very good
that's what she says when i start like
she knows spanish in restaurants and
[ __ ] like
like the cooks and like i i get along
with the kitchen so well dude i [ __ ]
love it like because they're like all
right who's this new dude and i'll start
speaking spanish with them and i'm like
and i hook them up with booze too so
they [ __ ] we're we're homies i love
you
so that's that [ __ ] dude language if you
know the language or the food
oh yeah super fast i got to learn
spanish man
just because i love the culture so
[ __ ] much and the women
i feel like if you work at a restaurant
for a while you pick up a lot of spanish
just because like other people work with
because a lot of the guys
that i worked with when i was in a
restaurant they all mostly spoke spanish
you definitely
find out the bad like mamon maricon yeah
yeah you found out the basket first
hotel [ __ ] maricopa
that was my nickname in high school yeah
i heard him handsome just walk around
they're like that's me man that's me i'm
handsome
yeah thanks man i'm like why but the way
i switch my hips
they love that [ __ ] though i feel like
mexican people they love giving people
in their hands for no goddamn reason
all day all day even though you don't
ask for it all day like what the [ __ ]
what's up [ __ ] gordo i'm like hey my
name is david
yeah dude
yeah cause i had white hair yeah these
comic or like
you know dumbo or [ __ ] idiot they
would call me
you're a fire what's a [ __ ] idiot no
no no no no that's spanish that's my
name yeah
but what's that mean in spanish it means
[ __ ] idiot i'm like these guys love
me man wow these guys i'm in with the
community
i remember when i worked at giant
rockets there was a there's one cook his
name is ruben
and like he didn't speak any english to
me he didn't speak any english at all
but we would communicate with like kind
of like just
i would slap his ass he'd slap my ass
he'd grab my titty we do [ __ ] like that
all the time but we wouldn't he wouldn't
speak english to me at all
so one day in early in the morning he's
that he's he's uh
he's fixing the grill and i come up to
him and i used to always just
slap him hard as [ __ ] on the ass like as
hard as i could
and he'd be like i wait like he would
just say crazy [ __ ]
and we would like bond over that that's
and we'd kiss and stuff like it was so
fun dude wow
that was the sex the vessels were great
um
yeah he gave me the investments
okay so anyway
so i walked in reuben is facing the
grill and i walk up and i go
slap the [ __ ] out of his ass chicks bro
he turns around and it wasn't reuben it
was a completely new guy
his name was abel and it was like
[ __ ] yeah he's like hey don't don't i
don't do that gay [ __ ] huh like don't do
that [ __ ]
and i was like yo my bad bro i thought
you were reuben
but then afterwards he like he hated me
for like a week
and then we he got he was actually he
was one he became one of my favorite
cooks and then he started touching your
ass a little bit yeah yeah yeah
i'm okay with it yeah he's like you know
i don't do that gay [ __ ]
he's like why'd you say he was like
i just want to establish my [ __ ]
manliness yeah before everybody finds
out i'm gay and there was this one cook
i forgot his name but he would be like
hey fool like but he was like
he was like a greaser huh he and he i
think he was from like east los
angeles be like hey fool uh how you
smell beautiful dog
i'll be like um ask you the wrong guy i
don't know
man guys
yeah they pulled like a phone with like
like a f-f-o-n-e right foo
like phone and i was like no i was like
did you were you born in a prison yeah
what happened to you [ __ ] phone phone
phone like like phone food like
like like what i'm using right now and
you'd only use t9 he only had like
yeah and this is at the time where
everyone had like you know touch phones
yeah yeah
but he was that guy he was a good guy
though i liked i liked working with
those guys dude the kitchen is always
the [ __ ] is the restaurant
you like and i love it too because um
front of the house is all
like being nice and putting on the mask
and like everything's very
like you know customer service and you
go to the back and it's like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like it says all
gay jokes
funny [ __ ] like just sexual harassment
yeah
hilary just funny ass [ __ ] at all dude i
remember i was there there was this guy
this filipino dude i worked with
and it's me and this dude leo this
mexican dude who's cool as [ __ ]
and we're like making we just got there
in the morning like we're making coffees
and there was a gay dishwasher and he he
looked like the cat in the hat but like
gay like gay mexican version of catnip
so he looks like you mean he'd always be
like ah like that's he'd walk around and
be like
i don't know bro let's do it the
filipino dude comes up and then i'm
making my coffee comes up behind me he
goes
in your
it was [ __ ] hilarious hilarious
the kitchen is always that spot too
because it's it's such a high stress
level place
you have to make it fun and you guys are
on your feet all the time
and you're running you're working a
restaurant like there's no stopping
there's no like down time
you don't got time to chill like you're
always running around when you're
dealing with food people are so picky
and like if you [ __ ] up an order like
that comes back on you it's like a whole
[ __ ] gay mexican dudes man they they
always sound
like the way they look yeah like when
did you watch remember when we watched
the case
like the terrible case of gabriel
hernandez yeah and his uncle
yeah yeah i was like i already feel like
freddie mercury what his voice is going
to sound like and to the
[ __ ] t i love him
i was like to the [ __ ] team man i
know like 30 dudes like that yeah bro
gay mexican dudes are
the the best bro like this dude came up
like i i worked at the party you always
come up for these little like toothpicks
and in spanish a stick is called apollo
if you a little one is a palito it's
like
you add it or itada any word it's small
version right
so yeah
i'm giving you some dick so he'd always
come up he like and he literally always
walked with his
his wrists were always loose like this
and he'd be walking and he was like in
his 50s and [ __ ]
and yeah he would wear eyeliner and he'd
come up and he was like bengal
like i'm coming for a little palito yeah
i'd be like you want me to give you a
paleto and be like
see and i would give him a little
toothpick he's like grass yes i mean
like
glitter would just follow him for some
[ __ ] as he walks away [ __ ]
seven butterflies comes out from his
head a rainbow streamer
look at those butterflies already
dude the [ __ ] the kitchen is where
it's at dude it's the most funny [ __ ]
i never liked my server co-workers
because they were always like
some of them were just [ __ ] like they
just wouldn't hustle they would just be
like
they'd take their time and [ __ ] but then
all the dudes in the back were always
like
yo [ __ ] hustle let's go let's go
let's go and that's that's how it had to
be
and they'd call you a [ __ ] idiot from
time to time one of the best
like ponte las pilas in spanish so that
means like
like so literally what that means was
put in your batteries
ponte las pilas but that what it what
they're saying is like [ __ ] like
getting to work
hustle but i just love spanish because
it's like ponte las pilas like put the
[ __ ] batteries in your [ __ ] back
bro
and get the [ __ ] work but it's just
so
funny dude spanish is hilarious
like get the [ __ ] work put your
batteries in like what the [ __ ] are you
doing bro that's why i want to learn
there's so many like cool like spanish
idiots and it's like funniest it's like
it's way funnier than this is so funny
dude like it's it's one of the funniest
[ __ ] things like i'll just hear
random things and i'll just start crying
laughing
but there's no way to like i can tell
you what it means in english but it's
just it doesn't translate it doesn't
translate to me all the time just like i
wish you knew spanish and i was like
that's like the same thing with with
korean is one of those asian languages
that have a lot of curse words
so like i feel like sometimes when i get
angry i actually curse in korean and it
feels better
yeah it's very very descriptive like
there's this thing my mom used to say to
me all the time and like
she would look at me and she goes
that means like you [ __ ] literally
hanging piece of dog [ __ ]
literally she would call me a
dingleberry wow yeah and there's no
[ __ ] up i remember that means you're
not even [ __ ]
i would repeat these korean words just
some when i'm walking around and [ __ ]
just because it was so casual that my
mom would curse at me 24 7.
and then people would be like yo why why
don't you talk like that like you talk
like like a [ __ ] like
korean like thug i'm like what do you
mean that's how my mom [ __ ] talks
they're like your mom
speaks to you like that i was like and i
started repeating the stuff my mom would
say they're like that's
pretty [ __ ] up would call my mom i'm
like hey why do you talk to me like that
she goes
mommy crazy like you don't just say [ __ ]
like that to your [ __ ] kid
like she would always tell me to go kill
myself all the time wow
she was just like why don't you just go
kill yourself and i mean in korean it's
not as intense right so like one of the
most popular korean phrases is
like do you want to die like you would
she would say that profusely to us
growing up would do you want to die yeah
she goes
she bought them like you want to die
right now yeah and that's like some
normal [ __ ] you say to a five-year-old
yeah yeah
all the [ __ ] time so like korean is
like very intense that's true yeah
there's certain [ __ ] like that where
like i i like that you said that where
it's like go
go kill yourself but it's not like as
intense as as it is in english
because like my mom sometimes should be
pissed at me too my mom's crazy like
says crazy [ __ ] all the time she reminds
me of your uncle like your uncle's story
like you're like when you're training my
mom uh but she would like she'd be mad
at me and she'd be like
like we've all heard that but that
literally translates to [ __ ] your mother
like she's
my mom is saying and i'm like
a kid and i want to be like that's you
though and then she beats my ass
you know the stuff same [ __ ] happened to
me so when i when i started getting
really good at korean
my mom would always call me keseki which
means son of a [ __ ] because
one time my mom was like he's like
that means you [ __ ] [ __ ] i looked
at my mom and i'm like
mom like in korean i'm asking her i'm
like are you calling me a kid give me
the son of a dog and i'm like
well you're my mom so aren't you the dog
she goes oh so now you speak korean
she starts beating my hand all of a
sudden
oh now you're suddenly fluent in korean
dude i remember my mom when like she
went
we had one interaction like that and i
she got mad at me and she started
slapping me
and i put my hands up to just block my
face like just like this
and she was like you put your hands up
to your own mother
it's like i'm protecting my [ __ ] face
dude like i got my ass
i used to have to work in my parents
store every [ __ ] saturday you know
sometimes that's just exhausting i'm not
in a great mood but
i i had to carry a bunch of these
supplies into the to the store
and when i'm the store kind of swings
open and closes really hard
and so when i was opening the door they
came back and slammed on my hand
and i went [ __ ] but she kind of knew
that i was in a bad mood already but she
thought i was cursing at her but she
doesn't know that you can't say [ __ ] to
a person yeah
[ __ ] you don't go [ __ ] but all she just
kept saying to me when she goes
more which means what what [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] she kept singing
and then she went to the back grab this
bamboo stick there was this green
thin bamboo stick that she would whip my
ass and she [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
me
but she didn't know and i kept not
trying to explain to her as i'm getting
my ass beat like
i wasn't saying it to you my head got
slammed
[ __ ] oh she [ __ ] she just kept whooping
my ass dude
she would be and her moral [ __ ] high
ground was so weird because she would
she would say
she would tell my dad don't you you
could beat them but don't you ever hit
them in the face i'm like
does it matter yeah right you're beating
the [ __ ] out of it i'm terrified
i'm [ __ ] either way yeah i'm very
scared
that little green bamboo stick was used
to kind of hold up plants and like
almost eight
oh i know exactly you know exactly yeah
yeah so i used to call that [ __ ] the
destroyer because you couldn't
and it was like ribbed it was so fast
you couldn't see it
but you could hear it it was like a
switch it was pretty much a switch it
was a switch it was so [ __ ] painful i
remember when my grandma beat me with
that [ __ ] she had it too
and finally one day when she smacked me
upside the head with it it snapped
i thought like i broke excalibur i
snapped the sword
like never never again dude
i didn't know that that [ __ ] came in
like a 24 pack and i remember
24 because she went behind this old
couch that we had
took this pack out it was so [ __ ]
dusty because that stick didn't break
and it said it had so durable the yellow
and blue sign that said 24 count
oh and then she whipped out a fresh one
this podcast is brought to you by
raycon my friends are you listening to
your music
with wired earbuds do you also drive a
car with an a track in it
is that your form of music because
that's how dated it
is i'm telling you right now if you
don't own yourself a pair of raycon
earbuds
you are missing out let me just give you
a few pointers why you already know
raycon earbuds start at about half the
price
of any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market and they sound just as
amazing as other top audio brands you
know
now i've had a lot of other wireless
earbuds before and probably one of the
most annoying things that i had to deal
with was
even if they didn't have wires the case
was so bulky
and they didn't charge them that well
either well these raycon earbuds the
they're super compact on top of that
they feel
amazing and they fit in your ears really
light and super comfortably so
i actually use these raycon earbuds
whenever i go biking or if i'm out
because i don't want to deal with wires
and i also don't want to deal with the
bulk of having a large
charging case well now's the time to get
the latest and greatest from raycon get
15
off your order at byraycon.com brain
that's by raycon dot com slash brain for
15
off raycon wireless earbuds by raycon
dot com
slash bright the bad guy and then they
turn they look and there's like a whole
army
exactly like [ __ ] beat the living [ __ ]
and there was a certain point too where
my
my dad didn't i think my grandma really
didn't [ __ ] like me
because there's a certain point where my
dad wouldn't allow me to go to my
grandma's house
which was his mom because she would beat
me specifically a lot more than my
brother
damn and so my brother was like the
golden child he would do really well in
school
but i used to get beat excessively and
the last time that i got beat
my grandma hit me in the face with that
stick and it welted all across my face
and it was [ __ ] in my eye
and my dad got so [ __ ] mad he didn't
let my grandma see me for a whole
[ __ ] month because that's when child
services gets involved
and that's when you're in trouble yeah
and so like it was crazy it's so funny
because like even though i i had that
memory for her i have like such fond
memories of her yeah
but i do remember she [ __ ] hated my
guts like she [ __ ] hated me but she
was great
my cousin told me the story where i
didn't know about this [ __ ] but
apparently my grand my grandma didn't
like my mom
at all because my gran my mom is
actually six or seven years older than
my dad
so you know like in asian culture that
shit's like what the [ __ ] yeah you're
supposed to marry people six or seven
years younger if you're a guy
so um when we when we were living in
texas at the time
um my i guess my dad was there and they
were all having dinner my cousin tells
me the story so they're all having
dinner
and my grandma out of nowhere just goes
accuses my mom of cheating on my dad
wow she goes i bet you your second son's
not even
like your actual son so i guess up until
that point she assumed that i was some
kind of [ __ ] latchkey kid
oh no wow she was right right
[ __ ]
but my dad my my cousin told me he's
cracking up he goes bro like i remember
that [ __ ] is the biggest fight that we
ever had in the house in texas
and everybody's screaming at each other
and then our grandpa
people are yelling standing up screaming
at each other she's eating dinner
just sick of this [ __ ] just eating his
food that i don't know he just goes
[Applause]
top of his lugs and the whole table gets
quiet he just goes
he turns when he turns into goku
he's screaming at the top of his super
saiyan out of nowhere and everybody gets
quiet and just
goes back to his [ __ ] food and just
starts eating
and they never went back to that topic
ever again wow yeah you brought some
[ __ ]
you brought up some [ __ ] she's just like
saying i'm getting sick of all you
[ __ ]
who the [ __ ] just screams out of nowhere
i think that's the only way to like stop
[ __ ] like that you know wow
if i fire with fire especially when
you're old you just don't give a [ __ ] i
respect you like that's [ __ ]
yeah you get so sick of their [ __ ]
you're just like dude
six with the tail he had the monkey bro
damn
you want to murder my cousin i obviously
was like one years old at the time
and i wasn't in the states yet but my um
i guess they brought my mom over first
but my
uh my cousin told me that he just
started screaming like just like that
everybody just went dead [ __ ] silent
wow yeah
yeah that's the ultimate trump card
you're like all right dude this guy's
gonna murder us
yeah if we go any longer we're all gonna
be dead a dude is just
exploding at the corner that's like just
self-destructing
could you [ __ ] imagine a guy who's
eating food and he's quiet and then just
puts his [ __ ]
knife and fork down super gently
like yo what the [ __ ] is this this guy's
gonna [ __ ] murder us
bro that's so funny that's yeah cause
like there's so much emotion that
literally words just can't
like it's just an overload of like this
just has to come out
my grandpa would never really talk to us
when we were younger like i just
remember him being super quiet to
himself
and he would hate if we would have too
much fun
it's the most old that's the most old
asian [ __ ] ever bro like
we would be watching like i remember i
got my ass beat
while laughing my ass off because i
couldn't stop laughing at some [ __ ] that
i saw on tv
and we were laughing so [ __ ] hard my
grandpa came out and he was just like
because he loves yelling right and he
was telling us to be quiet but i
couldn't stop laughing so he started
beating our ass
but i was crying because it hurt but i
was also crying because i couldn't stop
laughing
so he just hated us having fun all the
time he wanted everything to be quiet
the the guy used to play [ __ ] with
himself
all the time and then in the morning he
would do like a handstand for like 15
minutes straight
handstands handstands wow yup this guy
lived until he was 98.
damn almost to 100. what the [ __ ] good
for him
key to life dude handstands handstands
just start screaming
and suppress joy scream you can't have
too much fun or like your life goes out
of your body
you have to have a
being in a [ __ ] korean family as a
kid like i think my
experience is unique though because i
share these stories with other korean
people they're like
what the [ __ ] i'm like korean right
they're like
that's not a korean thing david it's
like that's how you think
you think bro that's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah man i got so many [ __ ] childhood
stories it's unreal like
and you don't really remember this stuff
until like you get older you get a
little old and i'm like oh this this was
kind of [ __ ] up
yeah yeah it just starts making sense i
think so maybe i'm this way because of
this
yeah that's exactly what it is like i
live with like sometimes
like when i live with tiff because like
she'll do certain things and she won't
get mad at me like
like my mom used to always um she would
like
get so mad at us when she's cleaning
stuff that we like [ __ ] up or just
cleaning in general
she would just be yelling at us all the
time and then like i associate
that with like any time like tiff is
cleaning the house i'll be like hey are
you mad at me
and she goes no stop being [ __ ] weird
dude and i was like
can i can i help you with something she
was like no i said i would do it like
just let me do it get the [ __ ] away from
me and i'll be like no but like you you
want me to like
and she's like get the [ __ ] out of here
and i'm like all right sorry and i'll
just sit back down
and i'll just like start crying i'll be
like oh dude this is crazy i think i
have trauma dude
you know when you're when you're in
these long-term relationships like i
think what i started finding out was
that
you actually find out more about
yourself than you do about the other for
sure
like you find out stuff that irritates
you a lot more that you didn't realize
irritates you
yeah you find out like how sometimes
[ __ ] up your personal life it's your
own [ __ ] yeah like when sometimes
like when tiff will turn on the air
conditioning i'll have like this sense
of like we have to turn it off
oh yeah because growing up as a kid we
we'd never use the air conditioning
we would never use a heater air
conditioning like my mom would give us
hand fans and be like yeah use this
[Laughter]
and then so like i'll be in my i have my
office in my
in my house and it gets so hot because
there's no ventilation
and it's like it's the one part of the
house that's not shaded by a bunch of
trees
so it's like burning hot and i'm on my
computer like trying to work
and i'm sweating perfectly he looks like
he's breaking to the pentagon and i'm
just like
i'm almost here i'm just yeah i'm just
typing away
and then like tiffa walking and she's
like
i'm saying that's just why the winter
leaves fell so did my heart
into my stomach when you came before my
eyes damn ties
i wish i could write like that i wish i
could write like that and then civil
coming like hey it's really hot in here
please turn on the ac and i'll be like
nah that's fine
she's like turn it on right taco
taco meat raw pink me ain't talking
about kabuki
i'm sorry i should've studied it over
and over again i'm on microsoft word
and i'm just saying that to my clients
so yeah that's like that's my life story
mariel's kind of like that too where she
doesn't want to turn on the ac but
i kind of move past that now i'm turning
on the [ __ ] ac yeah like
i started to realize how important it is
instead of saving 100 bucks
i should probably sleep yeah right right
yeah
sleep is a little more important than a
hundred dollars like i was
i would wake up and i'll have a sweat
angel on my bed and i'm like but i say
twelve dollars
didn't sleep a [ __ ] ounce yeah that's
so weird
that's crazy bro i don't like the noise
of air conditioners for some reason
though like the noise
irritates the [ __ ] out i like the white
noise it doesn't it doesn't drown out
like for me it like whenever i hear like
i like obviously being in the cool space
but
like it just reminds me of an office
like i feel like
in offices i always hear that dude that
like hum that
that ominous hum i always have to sleep
with the window open though because i
need i need circulating air mm-hmm
if i don't like i'll wake up in the
middle of the night because the air
feels dead
like i can't breathe because it feels
like suffocating me wow wow yeah so like
even like the other night that's [ __ ]
weird huh yeah man
you can't sleep you just start yelling
mario wakes up like yo dave what the
[ __ ] are you doing
so it actually feels it feels like
somebody has like a blanket over my face
so i'll wake up like that and i'm just
freaking out and i'll open the window
and some cool air will come in and then
i'll start falling asleep
wow yeah i can't i can't sleep with dead
air what if someone blows on your face
who's the voice is blowing in my face no
no you there's there's people you can
hire for that
[ __ ] muriel did the funniest thing so
she talks in her sleep a lot and
as she's sleeping i'm still awake on my
phone i couldn't sleep after this
because she scared the [ __ ] out of me
but this is this is an exact
replica or representation of how she
screamed i'm sleeping and all of them oh
i'm not sleeping i'm laying in bed and
she's sleeping and she goes
oh
and i go what the [ __ ] hey hey are you
okay are you okay
she goes i had a dream i was walking
down a hall
and there were stairs and this guy
grabbed me and threw me down and i was
screaming
and she [ __ ] sleeps right after she
screamed oh
this [ __ ] [ __ ] woke me up and i had
nightmares
because of that horrific scream i heard
at 3am that's her falling down the
stairs
that's the sound of her screaming
falling down
[Music]
i should account for that in her dreams
that's good wow
she's the only person that can uh
[ __ ]
like fall asleep right after she just
woke up wow
she'll that's a talent she's she a heavy
sleeper oh she's a heavy [ __ ]
that's why easy [ __ ] which is great
because i snore so she just [ __ ]
knocked the [ __ ] out nice you snore only
when i'm on
well i'm facing up i snore when i'm on
my side i don't snore
one time tiff told me she goes you were
talking last night and i was like really
i was like what did i say and she's like
looking at me and she's like you wanna
know what you said
and i'm like yeah she's she's like i
wake up
and i start talking and then she says
you started saying
uh why don't you just uh grab that
jumper over there and just go for like
about three minutes
and then i went back to sleep so you
dreamed about your job
yeah wow what a waste of a [ __ ] dream
yeah that's the loser-ish thing i've
ever heard in my [ __ ] life dude
like you said what are you saying you're
[ __ ] sleep i'm gonna [ __ ] organize
these files and then i'll get the papers
right to you okay
in about two minutes just uh seven more
reps and then we're all done
at least mario was [ __ ] being
murdered by some stranger i get murdered
in my dreams too bro oh yeah tell me
tell me the time you were [ __ ]
murdered please let me know right now
when were you murdered
somebody threw me down some stairs
i know so i have so many [ __ ] vivid
dreams you wouldn't even believe it dude
i got so many like what what do you got
um give me your best [ __ ]
damn top five top three top two actually
i actually write all my dreams down
uh and you're [ __ ] you dude you write
down your dreams
you [ __ ] lose a tree you're making
fun of me you know
my born ass dreams you might [ __ ] you
got a dream journal
when you say it like that it sounds way
weird why do you why do you have to call
it a dream journal why'd you call it a
dream
or do you have a dream called a dream
you have a dream catcher over your
[ __ ]
dream catalog dude you call it a dream
journal it sounds so loser-ish
all right dream catalogue i'm not sure
about my dreams well
let's go into my dream journal she pulls
it out so
uh so tell me tell us about your best
dream journals you [ __ ] idiot so
recently i had a dream
so you had dreams so you have a dream
when you can do anything
you don't have dweebs i i always had
these very odd dreams that never
that always like interweave and connect
to some other [ __ ] right so
i was in this like southern ass country
don't know where the [ __ ] it is but
there was this house right
so when i'm chilling outside i own this
house in the stream
and i'm having a conversation with a
couple of my friends from sacramento or
whatever
and suddenly as we're speaking uh the
sunset goes away and it gets super
[ __ ] dark
instantaneously like you know like when
uh this is very gradual but it's super
quick just [ __ ]
and it just becomes super dark and then
everybody starts to freak out you've got
a time lapse
so everybody starts to freak out and
they go oh and they look at me they go
are you ready and i'm like are you ready
for [ __ ] what they're like
it's time i'm like it's time for [ __ ]
what and then i just start
i look at my [ __ ] body and i have
like this assault rifle on me i'm like
geared the [ __ ] up yeah
yeah and we're going in and immediately
i know that inside this house
in order for me it's it's an airbnb that
i rented out i don't know why i know
this yeah
you know these cot these scenarios are
there you set the stage already yeah and
so
we're supposed to go into this airbnb he
goes like well we need to [ __ ] rent
this place out but there's
there's there's [ __ ] zombies in there
and i'm like well what the [ __ ]
you know me still being me i'm like why
don't we go somewhere else
like no we need to [ __ ] get rid of
this [ __ ] like this is our duty to
because you have to rent it out for
tomorrow because you're guests coming in
like it's our duty the [ __ ]
minimum you know a lot of money to
protect deposits to protect people
and so when i go inside it's not even
just regular zombies it's [ __ ]
vampire zombies so they don't just eat
you they suck your blood whoa
it's like that movie with josh hartnett
the 40 40 knights i've never seen that
[ __ ]
i don't watch movies i actually work so
i don't include [ __ ] weird catalogue
so sex in the city is a great show you
guys my favorite movie is probably the
second one perfect yeah continue
so as i'm as i'm walking into this
[ __ ] house and this house looks like
one of those
kind of ranch style homes very big
one-story home we go inside
literally i've never felt so good with a
gun in my life dude
i'm blasting the [ __ ] out of these
people you're john wicking it up dude yo
john wick plus dragon ball z is me oh
[ __ ] i'm talking about i did this one
[ __ ]
round my [ __ ] mind like i walked up i
kicked off the wall i did a flip and i
said
these [ __ ] in the head i'm
killing everybody dude you should write
a screenplay it's dope
it's insane so i'm like literally
blasting all these [ __ ] vampire
zombies in their head
part that freaked me out the most was
there was this one room that i had to go
through it was a red door
oh no and that's always the ghost that's
my ghost story
and you can hear a girl screaming for
help on the other side aiming for help
and in my mind i know that if i go and
it's a trap but then
me being the hero that i am like i have
to go into this [ __ ] room
because i already just murked a bunch of
[ __ ] zombies like what's five more
zombies right
walked inside and there's this girl in
this dark room
red light lit up she's there and she's
eating the carcass of another young girl
oh
i start to freak the [ __ ] out like in
this dream i'm freaking the [ __ ] out i
just get my gun i start
blasting this little demon girl right
but none of the bullets are affecting
her and she's just walking up towards me
slowly slowly slowly and then the people
behind me are trying to push me saying
no you gotta [ __ ] kill it but they
won't let me out the room
so they're pushing me but they won't
these are my setup it's a setup like you
have to kill it she's getting closer and
closer and closer whoa i freaked the
[ __ ] out somehow
i struggled past him i run outside and
when i run outside it's sunset again and
it's not dark
i get into this like this uh this chevy
suburban and we're walking in like yo we
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
and it's weird because now when i walk
into the suburban it's my car when i was
in the front seat but now i'm in the
back seat and there's an uber that i
wake up
i've had that exact same dream actually
like word for work
back on the uber room what the [ __ ] it's
so wild
i have these vivid [ __ ] dreams and it
always happens because i can't
when i don't sleep well yeah so it's
like when i'm off and on asleep i can
remember all this weird [ __ ]
damn and so like i i always feel like
i'm writing them down because it feels
like an omen for something else
obviously none of this stuff has ever
come true did you kill a bunch of people
in a house one day
is that where this dream comes from is
that your own let's move on did you
murder some people at a
airbnb i what did you murder a bunch of
people
at an airbnb is that why you're having
this dream what's murder
what is emergency murder right now did
you touch these young girls
with young girls at what age is this
young girl it's a very good argument
yeah question how old is 16 and you're
like wow yeah you're right
well today we're going to get into an
advice column because people have been
nobody has actually gotten advice from
the trio
oh man here we go they're ready for some
bad advice guys here we go this one is
to um i'm always going to leave your
guys's name out because i'm assuming
that you
probably don't want me to say your name
but his last name is
zhang okay let's go to the social
security number let's call him ping pong
x i o and g he is mong obviously um
my name is ting tong zhang i'm hmong and
i'm 23 years old
i've been wondering about how to save
myself
for what marriage what is this a little
bit about my life situation right now
is i broke up with my girlfriend um [ __ ]
tough dude
we dated a little over six years damn's
a long [ __ ] time
uh i saw her almost every day since we
started dating loser to me i felt like
i'm kidding to me it felt like marriage
because i spent all my time with her we
went out together
coach slept partied shopped and
basically we did everything together
the reason why we broke up was because
of something he said i said two years
ago
damn she's musical [ __ ] remember
what'd you say yeah she's an elephant
she said she's nellie you remember
everything what i said was
why can't we be like me and my cousin or
wait what
my cousin and i i don't know what that
means that sounds really wait what
uh at that time i wasn't really thinking
straight and shouldn't have compared my
relationship with my cousin
what i wanted to tell her was i wanted a
healthy relationship
yeah i'm getting a little weirded up
which i did explain to her later during
our argument two years ago and no i
didn't say that because i want to get
with my cousin
is why can't we be like my cousin and i
plus she is my first cousin
you're not helping yourself right now
i wrote this dude i would say yeah
oh man dude well first of all wait wait
what the [ __ ] i have no idea what the
[ __ ] i i understand word vomit i
understand saying something that you
like
in your head makes sense but when you
say it out loud it's like
the dumbest thing ever but that's bad
that's really bad
what is he trying to say right now when
he was talking to his girlfriend he was
like why can't we [ __ ] like our cousins
yeah yeah yeah like why can't you
why can't i eat you out like i do with
my oh this [ __ ] is an elephant dude
she'll remember anything you say
i i'm pretty sure i would remember this
very specifically i feel like
that dude said he wanted to [ __ ] his
cousin one time
why do you remember everything it's like
sweetie i don't remember everything but
i remember that
at that time i wasn't really thinking
straight and then shouldn't have
compared my relationship with my cousin
uh what i wanted to tell her was that i
wanted a healthy relationship this all
still sounds weird man which i did
explain to her later during our argument
two years ago and no i didn't say that
because i wanted to get with my cousin
plus she is my first cousin i love her
no i'm kidding i'm explaining i'm
explaining this part because a lot of my
ex-girlfriend's family thought i wanted
to [ __ ] my cousin yeah
i think i think everybody bro it's the
way you [ __ ] phrased it yeah that's
bad man
that's really bad that's that's a rough
place to be it's like yeah well
you're when you're in a relationship you
shouldn't compare your relationship to
other people's relationships in the
first place
that's the first fallacy right the
second definitely don't compare it to a
relationship
with a family member also yeah and
that's that at any next
next topic at any time in any moment not
even
not even just in a relationship but
amongst friends at work
never should [ __ ] your cousins your
family ever be a thing that you
talk about you know like like comparing
a romantic relationship with
a platonic yeah like really weird like
why can't we just be like me and my
cousin
like i could maybe understand where
you're coming from but also just don't
that's a big no-no man that's a big well
i mean for us too as people who are on
the outside
there's if if there wasn't any nuance
there's no way that i would have
there's only one way for me to assume
that you want to [ __ ] your cousin yeah
let's say you're having an argument with
her right so you're having this
conversation with your girlfriend you're
like you know what
our relationship sucks we're not having
sex you don't suck my dick like you used
to i wish you were my cousin yeah
why can't you be like my cousin man it's
hilarious though that's
really [ __ ] funny though here's the
thing it's just uh
it's it's a bad choice of words
the problem sometimes with these
questions is like you wish you had more
context because
in their head they're giving you all
that they think that you need to hear
yeah like i wish there was a video
yeah on what happened like let me see we
need to know more backstory right
so based on the information you've given
us well there's more backstory oh [ __ ]
okay
okay cut you off okay
so i lost a couple of good friends
because they were her family even though
i met them before we dated which
which hurted quite a lot um thy english
not so great
that she heard it but she heard it you
know what dude i'm gonna do you a favor
and i'm going to autocorrect as i speak
uh no i don't nope i appreciate this guy
because he's a fan and i want to respect
him
my ex became very insecure about me as
he laughs
what are you talking about man after
what i said two years ago she didn't
want me to have any female friends
and and always thought i would try to
get with her cousins i didn't really
understand why because i showed her that
she can trust me by not talking to any
female for a whole year
stop talking slash not seeing my cousin
for two years
he stopped watching porn all right okay
wait wait
so okay okay okay this is a bad spot
dude
[Laughter]
is give more like feeling to the fact
you're validating her thoughts about you
wanting to [ __ ] your cousin dude this
sounds
like this sounds like a young
relationship right yeah i'm feeling this
we're talking about some young people
assuming like if you're 35 and this is
what you're writing in that we gotta
work on a lot of things but
but i'm assuming that they're young i'm
pretty sure you were you've been looking
at your cousin a little weird for your
for your girlfriend to be like you know
what man
there's something odd between you two
stay away from your [ __ ] cousins
that's the thing it's like if you had no
allegiance to like romantic relationship
with your cousin
you wouldn't have to say all these
things it should just be like
dude because i have cousins and i've
never ever
dude like like a like a girl cousin
would come through and she wants to talk
i'm like hey cool get the [ __ ] out of my
room huh you know what's funny is like
how he said it right he goes
you know and like i try to comparing our
relationship to my cousin
by the way she's my first cousin not
doing any favors bro yeah
because that's blood my guy yeah
but in the context yeah that's not
like if you're saying hey why can't we
be like me and my cousin
what's your girlfriend she's gonna be
like what the [ __ ] no she's my first
cousin it's not gonna help your
argument in that situation when you tell
your girl like look i won't even talk to
my cousin anymore
that's also why can't we just [ __ ] like
me my cousin
he's having trouble phrasing his words
yeah yeah it's just crazy
and we're having a little bit of fun but
also
yeah yeah and it's a little refreshing
well just to kind of put this into
perspective it's just like i think
you're having a lot of issues with
communication because you clearly don't
know how to express what you want to say
to your significant other yeah
especially when you make a romantic
comparison to a platonic
relationship there's no other [ __ ]
way for her to assume
i mean i guess like if she's giving you
the benefit of the doubt she wouldn't
assume that
but if she does feel that way maybe the
relationship with your cousin might be a
little [ __ ] yeah maybe it's valid
well i'm thinking
i'm thinking all right i'm trying to put
myself in this dude's shoes i'm
i think he's saying uh me and my cousin
get along really well
like we're cool we should i'm assuming
he has a close relationship with his
cousin that's not
sexual i'm assuming that uh and he's
probably just like why can't we get
along like me and my cousin
do yeah wrong a little weird to bring
that in
for a fight when you make uh comparisons
your comparisons are tough
but if at any time
your girlfriend makes you stay away from
your cousin for a year yeah that's about
that relationship's over
yeah like ultimately i can't even trust
you with blood
yeah yeah you can't be if your
girlfriend's like don't be around your
cousin
we need to reevaluate our lives yeah
yeah
i can't be with you because it does
sound like he's trying to make a grand
gesture like oh like i'll sacrifice this
but at the same time i'll sacrifice my
cousin
and he's like oh i'm not going to watch
porn anymore right no that's bad those
are all
like yeah no this is uh this is a
slippery but i understand like
you probably are looking for more of a
friendship
with your significant other he probably
has a cool relationship don't use
family dude that's rough man this guy
knows what he's doing
bringing the story back to the present i
decided to see my cousin again without
my ex's permission
wow wow that see that that's the
phrasing is bad
man i pray to god that english is not
your first language because you are
phrasing things
it really looks terrible let's continue
this i'm sorry but it's because
why would i need her permission just to
see my family probably because you made
sex eyes with her
we argued the whole day after i hung out
with my cousin we came to an
understanding but she talked to her
cousins like you loved
using that word cousin baby to her
cousins later that night and they told
her it was wrong of me
to put my cousin first over her for just
one day
she made me decide to either leave or
stay i told her i wanted to stay but i
needed a week to think over my emotions
because that cousin love was really
really strong oh cousin love
i actually decided that part yeah i was
going to say that right
i was like dude you're you're ruining
this
david you son of a [ __ ] you got me yeah
when she kept telling me no
you need to decide now so i told her i
didn't love her anymore because it
seemed like she didn't want to stay but
wasn't strong enough to leave
that's some r b lyrics bro yeah and now
i'm alone without her
more r b lyrics it's been hurting me
like crazy because even though we had a
lot of bad there were a lot of good
[ __ ] you brian mcknight i taught
i talked to friends
i talked to friends and some family but
it didn't seem to help me
i kinda wanna [ __ ] my cousin just be
more like her
please extra chromosomes i i worked out
i work out eat right and find new
hobbies
but nothing seems to heal me i'm feeling
lost and empty
i try not to bother friends every day
because i hate to be other people's
burden
so how does one save themselves because
i'm missing her love and
how she basically has she was basically
my drug addiction and
that i couldn't get rid of this is a
brian mcknight song dude this is a
first of all you need to [ __ ] become
a music writer because that [ __ ] right
there
you said bars
but in a serious note and i want you to
take this with a grain of [ __ ] salt
because you do remind me of me when i
have my very first girlfriend
and you need to take this once again
with a grain of salt but also take it to
heart you are the biggest [ __ ] loser
i've ever heard in my life
and the reason why but he says i would
love he says it to me all the time i say
i say that because you remind me of
myself when i was 18 years old
right now your identity as a human being
as a person is based on what somebody
else thinks of you
you are now only worth something because
this girl gave you value
you don't have personal value you can go
ahead and exercise do all this other
[ __ ] find other hobbies
but you're not really tackling the root
of the problem the root of the problem
is that you don't find value in yourself
so if you only feel whole because
somebody else tells you that you're an
amazing person
right now you're already [ __ ] up you
got to find that yourself first
and other thing too man let's just talk
about this stop talking about your
cousin
what is your cousin you said
you said cousin like eight times dude
how bad is she
like she's walking around hey cousin you
want to do bubble bath like we used to
because i'm stuck i'm in the laundry
can't get out
i got kind of drier my asshole's
what is going on this is like some weird
[ __ ] you gotta stop bringing up your
cousin man
is there something i like i'm so curious
because we got to do a follow-up with
this
yeah we need to follow up we need a
picture of the cousin
what's her only fans dude i think yeah
you nailed it on the head it's just you
got to work on yourself
number one uh number two uh once you get
that
once he does that like that'll settle a
lot of the problems but like what the
breakups suck no matter what even if you
do know yourself even if you like do
are cool with who you are and whatnot
like breakups are always going to suck
no matter what that [ __ ] stings
yeah and why are you expecting yourself
to get over a breakup so easy yeah right
time feels all right yeah and also like
just get yourself out there start
talking to other girls you know put
yourself back on the market you gotta
move forward man
yeah and you're supposed to feel bad
after a breakup for a while i mean the
only time i didn't feel bad i told the
story on the podcast where some women
were not very happy with this is when i
i fake cried after i broke up with
somebody just so i could make sure that
they felt like i cared
and yeah but sometimes you gotta do that
the laughing doesn't
does it help me right now i think so
many girls are like what
was that okay so i'll just tell the
story again
but i uh was with the girl and i pray to
god she's not listening to this podcast
she is i was with the girl and long
story short with her
she she kind of like lightweight cheated
on me a little bit and i thought my
feelings kind of disappeared but
with her i remember i broke up with her
over the phone because she was a
long-distance relationship
and this is why i was living in l.a she
cheated on you yeah all right then you
don't have to explain yourself
so i was like and i broke up with her i
was like listen i thought i could try
this
and she started bawling a little bit and
when she was crying i thought i would
feel something
bro empty yeah because [ __ ] because she
wronged you
and then i i i kind of didn't want to
like just hang up the phone so i started
fake crying i went
and i did it to spare her feelings yeah
honestly well any
what's but if you didn't feel anything
like i don't understand why people get
mad at you it's like you didn't feel
anything because and it's funny because
one
girl she goes if i ever found out like
say you and i were boy boyfriend
girlfriend i ever found you fake cried
i would be so [ __ ] pissed and when i
wrote back to her i was like well
sundance 2017 i'm a great actor you
would have never
they would have never [ __ ] known i
wonder why you like your cousin so much
man
i've never heard the cousin thing is
yeah there's a lot of cousin stuff in
there that i just kind of wasn't making
the connection like at first i was like
okay maybe they're cool but then it was
like
it's probably just a friendship thing
yeah but like i'm assuming
how weird is that friendship where your
significant other of six years
feels uncomfortable with the way that
you behave with them that's true but
also she was tripping about
porn and other girls he also probably
gave her a reason what was she tripping
about or did he volunteer
i don't know it's probably like a guilt
thing right it's like oh i think
i think this is what happened he goes
she goes i can't trust you well
fine [ __ ] it i'll get rid of my mom my
dad my cousin
and i'll get rid of porn and he went
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
because that's a thing like i've done
that in the past too within like my
relationship where
like i'll over lose not like i say no
not like
that big [ __ ] but i'll say like oh
like you say things that you think
that your partner wants to hear or that
they want you give me give me an example
pat you're
you're tiff and then you're you're
[ __ ] nick nick the ear
nick the queen what where's no let's
give let's
do a scenario right now
uh pat you're angry because nick keeps
on leaving his [ __ ] on his
uh [ __ ] boxers and he says that he
doesn't masturbate
okay nick you i mean your [ __ ]
boxers are stiff as cardboard all right
okay you know what i'm not gonna wear
underwear anymore i won't wear underwear
i don't have to wear anymore at all
i will wear pants i won't do any of that
how about that see that's an example
boom let me tell you something man you
should be a relationship counselor
that's it
that would solve every relationship i
love that [ __ ] what's the guy's name
again
huh i call him uh tong tong
you're welcome next dude i had an ex
when i lived with her she would trip on
point i think i told you guys about that
yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i don't know that whole that
whole
like i said there's too many variables
in this story i think you're right it
does sound like he was kind of like i'll
give up my mom
small things this is what i do right i
do the exact opposite of you it's like
what do you want i don't do that anymore
it's okay i was like when i first
started dating
i'll give up carbs for three hours how
about that does that show dedication
she's like
tomorrow wake up i'll do half the bed
what is that yeah and she goes half the
bed do the whole bed
fine [ __ ] it not a problem boom
she thinks that she [ __ ] doubled up
on her earnings but she really didn't
get [ __ ] there you go
that's a negotiator right there dude
that guy's a [ __ ] negotiator dude man
six year anniversary august 17th coming
up
wow wow i've been with her for six
[ __ ] long
long that's a long relationship i'm
telling you man i never thought i would
make it this far with her and i'll tell
you this right now
never wanted to [ __ ] my cousin yeah yeah
ever that probably [ __ ] the
relationship
oh i'm 100 like if you always talked
about your cousin
they'd be weird when you're sitting
around i'm like hey mario man dude my
cousin right
todd bad ass i wish you'd just blow me
like my cousin
and then i met a perfect kid like my
cousin dude yeah why can't you just kiss
like she does
yeah yeah that makes somebody bitter you
know like when you have a little bit
when you compare somebody else and what
you want out of somebody else's
relationship
with your own that's bad you can't do
that i think that's the first that's the
first blunder
you had i just if you got to not see
your family because of this relationship
there's just a lot
you got to think about your life like
you got to think about a lot of it has
to be
very serious there's a lot of things
going on there have you guys ever had
like an ultimatum that a partner has
given you no
yeah well the porn girl that she was
like don't watch porn
she was like i consider porn cheating if
you watch porn you're cheating on me
and uh delete all these girls off
instagram that like
i had acquired over the years of
instagram yeah
big booty pages like this is a good one
jiggle jiggle
yeah no like but i had to like go
through instagram delete everything and
she would like literally hit me up and
be like
who's this girl now and i'd be like [ __ ]
i mis there was a lot i missed one i'm
sorry
you know i don't know but that's a bad
that i should've we should have just
broke up
right there because like it was over
that's like it's done it's done like
what the [ __ ] am i jumping through these
hoops
like if you can't ex like that's an
insecurity on her part i'm being an
idiot for even trying to [ __ ]
like deal with this [ __ ] like [ __ ]
all that yeah it's not like [ __ ] your
cousin you know
yeah you're kind of you're kind of deep
in that [ __ ] man i don't know man i
don't like ultimatums i don't like when
somebody tells you you can't do
something or else
because like when somebody sometimes
people will propose the ultimatum to the
other person thinking that they would
make them happier with what you're
saying
but a lot of times they should be like
no that's not
that's not the point like a lot of times
you saying you're not gonna hang out
with your
family or cousins is missing the point
of what her issue is with you
you know what i mean also too like the
way you guys describe your relationship
sounded very unhealthy and once again
this is just my perspective of things um
of just the information that we have
yeah and when somebody tells me that i
spent
every waking moment with my partner
there's only a couple of people that i
know that are like that and they're all
[ __ ] asian immigrant parents right
because they only
have each other when they came here but
when you're with somebody and i this is
a truth for me that i've seen in
personal relationships with my friends
when they get with somebody that doesn't
have any [ __ ] friends it's always a
red flag
it's like what what reason is there that
you don't have a friend
right yeah right how do you not have a
single [ __ ] friend two code
yeah it's odd i don't i don't i don't
believe in that [ __ ] man no that is
weird that's not the way to go
yeah and to piggyback on what you said
about the ultimate
[Laughter]
yeah it's not about ultimatums it's
about you got to communicate and come to
it like an agreement an understanding
like where can i give blah blah blah but
if
you ever at a rhodium relationship
whether like if you don't do this then
it's over it's me and it's like it's
over you know what's kind of crazy too
that i hear a lot of people say is like
i've heard this a lot from girls too
that have told guys
um have been like hey like if like
they've been in a relationship for a
while and they're like hey if you don't
marry me by like
next year yeah it's like it's over and
it's like bro if you have to tell me
to marry you we should not get married
like that's so weird to like pressure me
into this [ __ ] marriage
[ __ ] muriel dude wait what
i'll tell you that
touch on something she's so dumb i love
her to death and i say dumb as in
beautiful yeah yeah so she's so
beautiful she's the most beautiful
person i've ever met in my life
turkey i wanted to propose to her
actually like when we were like three or
four years in like three years in or so
i'm not ready blah blah blah blah right
out of [ __ ] know where she goes
where's my ring and i'm like hold on a
second i
propose the idea of proposing to you
earlier but she started sweating me
after a while
but she didn't know that i actually had
a plan to propose to her in japan
but we have to go to japan first and
that was gonna be in march so
you know we were i was waiting for that
time to come up but that whole time she
goes
like she would do some subtle [ __ ] like
this i'm talking about this i'm like
i'm a little thirsty can you pass me a
glass of water that's funny how can i do
that without a ring on my hand
and i'm like oh you wanna be like that
wow you gonna be like that
that's cool you don't even know i'm
about to propose to you dumbass in
[ __ ] japan and i bought the ring yep
so she doesn't know but as as as i'm
about to propose to her that's how it
goes bro
i have the ring in my camera bag ready
to propose to we're ready to go
as we're going to the to the proposal
spot that i know that i want a proposal
we're at
she goes she goes would it be a terrible
idea if your brother
actually proposed to to his girlfriend
before you proposed to me i would i
would kill you and in my mind i'm like
[ __ ] you don't even [ __ ] know
you chuck it in the river i'm about to
blow your [ __ ] pupils out [ __ ]
you don't even [ __ ] know and she was
just talking so much [ __ ] all the way to
the proposal spot i'm like
damn my mother drowned this girl in this
river yeah you know wow
so but so it's like the angriest
proposal of all time i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] what this [ __ ] man
that you just fainted it's the most in
your face proposal
i want to say in your face but what
actually happened was i cried i was like
would you bury me
a real cry or a sundance cry no i legit
cried for
this one because i actually yeah all
right mr so i know what your deal is bro
i cried dude yeah
i'll cry right now i did too oh he's
having an aneurysm oh no
oh this is really hard stupid pressure
you guys talk about something else and
i'll try how i swear to god
so so ting tong um just uh
i can't do it
wow what's your closing thoughts on on
uh ting tong
stop being a [ __ ] loser dude stop
basing your whole life off of one
person like first of all you sound super
young so if you think that the first
person that you're with that you've ever
had a five six year relationship that's
going to define you for the rest of your
life it's not that it's not
you'll find people right now who have
fell in love
they they were together with their
husband or wife for 30 years 30 or 40
years
cancer takes them away and that was the
love of their life but they still
somehow five
six years later they find somebody else
to love yeah like that's
it's malleable things change all the
time like if you're dwelling on this
stuff
why dwell on it life is [ __ ] short
i'm not saying not to cherish what you
guys had
and maybe not reflect on you talking
about [ __ ] your cousin all the time
maybe make some adjustments you know i
mean switch up the game plan you know
you're throwing the one two too much
throw a three in there yeah slip yeah
hey this is your past relationship is
data that you've collected yeah you take
that you improve on it
and you take it to the next relationship
it's trial and error
and heartbreak stuck no matter what
that you have to go through you'll meet
new people new cousins will come around
you know what i mean like
i feel like in his next relationship
he's going to listen to this podcast and
be like i heard what they said
babe why can't we just [ __ ] like my
brother
guy so yeah you're right not use the
cousins sisters or brothers probably
family yeah if you're trying to compare
yourself to like a a good relationship
with somebody just don't use any family
members kardashians
just use somebody else don't ever
compare your relationship to another
relationship
or just say what the qualities of the
relationship you want to have like why
can't we just be happy together and
have fun and crack jokes yeah and you
know shoot the [ __ ]
comparison is the thief of joy right is
that what it is i think i think
i think you've got it guys the dog barks
to the moon
but the moon never barks back dog
yeah yeah remember that dude when the
willow
whispers at night it yawns at the dawn
and your whispering eye is what is wrong
underneath my heart
ain't talking about kabuki kabuki come
on dawg
amen i know he's running praise the lord
yeah well everybody that wraps up the
most useless episode let's do another
one let's do another one do you have
another one yeah
the most worst advice for this game is
we might as well do one more let's do
another one
i think that was a good one i think so
dude start off a little round i mean
i think it was good i'll tell you this
we got to make jokes out one of the most
you gotta you gotta crack a little joke
well it's hilarious because i didn't
think this guy would mention his cousin
so many times yeah there's a lot of
cousins
if you were to type apple f and type in
cousin it would be
one out of the whole
oh this is a good one this is from
anonymous we'll call her um mabanga
mabanga i like it
uh i would like to stay anonymous for
this please of course
my boyfriend and i have been together
for almost three years first of all
thank you for knowing how to write and
speak english i helps me out a lot
commas is amazing yes in the last year i
noticed that he doesn't find interest in
having sex or doesn't seem to be
interested in touching me in general
oh [ __ ] that's right he is the type of
person who doesn't like the show pda
which is public displays of affection
but when we are together privately
he's a little [ __ ] no uh we see we seem
even more distant
oh that's worse that is weird yeah a
couple months ago i was uncovering some
underlying trauma with my therapist
we've talked about my sexual assault
from my last partner oh that's deep girl
and she advised me to take
anti-depressions i don't think that's a
good idea
to work through my therapy session there
was a week where i wanted to have sex
because
i was having immense amount of pressure
and stress from work while having
while having sex it wasn't pleasurable
and we had to stop i don't know if i
offended him or hurt his feelings
because since then he won't have sex
with me anymore
i want to say it's been about seven to
eight months since we last had sex
is there anything i can do to talk to
him and have a conversation about this
without making him upset or should i
just leave it and wait until he's ready
to have sex again
uh first of all that's not a problem
that just you leave alone and it fixes
yourself right you gotta bring that [ __ ]
up yeah
and be like yo can we talk about the
elephant in the room
and why don't you break my back back
no but seriously though i think you have
to talk because
yeah you have sex is very important in a
relationship well i mean this is this is
such a weird thing right
i think like the the situation is very
weird because you are finding out things
about yourself that even you didn't know
right and now that he's also finding
this stuff about you too and
specifically because it deals with
sexual assault and a previous partner
yeah he could be going through something
right now where he doesn't want to fall
into that category
himself now he might be scared he's
scared maybe he doesn't know how to
be around you anymore maybe the stuff
that he thought that he enjoyed having
sex with you
he's like oh am i being too rough am i
am i am i bringing up trauma for you now
so yeah
if you guys don't first of all never
ignore these type of issues right and if
you guys do have a one-on-one
conversation and it doesn't work then
that therapy session is gonna have to be
for both of you yeah
right yeah yeah no i mean communication
is key like you have to talk about what
the [ __ ] is going on you can't like you
said it won't
fix itself you have to talk and you can
approach it like you don't have to
obviously don't be like why aren't we
why are we not having sex like just talk
and be like hey
like even like before you have the
conversation be like
that whole like hey i want to talk to
you later today i have some things i
want to talk about
in the relationship blah blah blah you
don't like this whop yeah
we broke up obviously but during this
time uh
she was consistently when i would look
at her she would
piss me off yeah i mean specifically
because she and i just were very
combative human beings we couldn't
really
see eye to eye on a lot of things and i
think what kind of kept this together at
the time was that we had really good sex
so that was boy
you know what i'm saying i don't know
how you blow it back out when you're
always on your back
david figuring it out though david
figured it out he's like i'm a man of
many solutions
don't do the work you know this guy's
good man
i honestly oh yeah i was like i was in
this relationship
right now you know there's sexual
chemistry with this girl but you didn't
she she we were just in such a bad place
we just didn't we didn't have sex for
almost like three months and
i was young at the time and you know
having sex is something that when you're
young you just want to [ __ ] off
yeah but for her because there was such
an emotional disconnect and every time
we spoke to each other we got into a
fight
i just i literally found her as the most
unattractive [ __ ] human being
yeah yeah i would look at her like when
she would open her mouth i'm like what
kind of
[ __ ] diarrhea is going to come out of
that mouth today yeah right and so
you know whether she was in the mood or
i was in the mood it didn't really
[ __ ] matter i just didn't want to be
touched by her
yeah so that's a good place to be when
there's those emotional emotions when
there's emotional turmoil
it's it's hard to connect and i i feel
like if you're not [ __ ] just the [ __ ]
right and you're in a committed
relationship
that emotional aspect of having sex is
very very important
and once that's gone absolutely it's
it's really hard to come back from that
yeah there's times where you can look at
your partner when everything is right
and they look like the most beautiful
person on earth
and when they irritate you you're like
you look your [ __ ] looks like morgan
freeman's face
like just fresh still beautiful just
freckled just dotted for no reason
it looks like a baseball bat you have a
great voice yeah i mean
he's like your vagina's going to tell me
a really deep story it's going to
narrate what i'm there
about shawshank the penguins marched all
the way to malaysia i'm telling you man
like you you're with you're with these
people in this relationship and like
emotionally things aren't working out
yeah it's supposed to happen like you're
how are you gonna have sex with somebody
that you feel so emotionally
disconnected with you yeah and it sounds
like you don't know what's going through
his head
and yeah you're making assumptions yeah
so it's hard because i feel like for him
there could be i i would imagine his
position it might be really tough
knowing your past history and being able
to like knowing what to do like not
yeah taking the wrong steps so a lot of
it could be that and a lot of it could
just be like i just don't want to make
it worse or
he knows that you're going through a lot
too so people just don't
want to have uncomfortable conversations
yeah exactly but for this you have to
have this conversation
and you should feel both you guys should
feel somewhat
like safe have this conversation with
each other because it's um
you guys are trying to like grow with
each other if if that's the case you
guys are trying to like work things out
so you guys should try to figure out
where he's coming from
and he should be trying to figure out
where you're coming from and if that's
not there on his side
then you know that's not a good sign
right every time i hear this
relationship stuff
i'm always trying to picture how nick
would deal with it
it's like we haven't had sex in a while
i want to talk about i feel nick just
like
what do you want i'm like i'll be like
six now six now i'm talking like
what do you want from me i'm not a
machine
guys she's like i got two minutes and
that's it that's what i talked to
two minutes of pure unadulterated sex
of pure rage my baby that's my time hey
baby
my baby and she's like don't talk like
that to me have you ever hooked up with
like some random person i know my guy
over here be getting that what what no
honestly tiff has been the only person
that i have uh
had a relationship with and i've had sex
with wow wow
do you like a romeo and juliet
because it's awesome when i talk to
other people about that it's like uh
they don't really have a similar like i
got lucky with tiff like we're
i feel like personality wise we're
really very compatible
we we're we're friends like you know
like she's like
she's my best friend but but she's my
lover though
cut cut the machismo out man just say it
i'm a little softy though dude hey man
just just say how you feel about tiff
right now because i'm gonna cut this
out i tell her this all the time because
i like when i hear other people go
through like their dating stories and
like when they're trying to meet other
women i'm like
for me and tip i really honestly
genuinely feel that she checks all the
boxes that i'm looking for in a partner
what are those boxes like she got a fat
old ass bro like
she her lips toxic masculinity seeps in
again
she's very supportive she never uh she
never
kind of like she she believes in me more
than i do
you know what i mean she always has my
back she she
she looks out for me in ways that i can
never imagine and she's empathetic
she she you know it everything you're
not
exactly like she she compliments me very
well so what do you do for her trash bag
[ __ ] i cook for her i make
i cook for her um i clean the toilet
every now and then
um let's go dumpster boy tell me what
tell me what you do for her
she supports you she makes you believe
in yourself what do you do besides take
her spirit and soul away
tell me i use our money tell me what
else what else do you do
i sleep on her i take her pillows nice
um you've given her covet three times so
far
um i bought her i bought her dinner a
couple times that was about it that's
pretty good
her birthday is tomorrow so shout out to
my girl on her birthday i'll tell you
this though it's really hard having like
for me anyways just hooking up with
somebody so there was a point weird yeah
there's a lot of stuff that i did only
because i was a stand-up comic because i
needed to have life experiences that
other people had in their stand-up sets
that i didn't have
because i grew up very [ __ ] religious
i i when i was younger too if i said the
word [ __ ]
it literally felt like satan grabbed my
ankles and he was dragging me to hell
because that's what was happening to you
yes specifically to you that's what it
felt like it felt like if i said
[ __ ] it i was going to go to hell that
instant
but i started cursing more often because
instead of punching random [ __ ] when i
got mad it was better just to verbally
let it out and just say how i feel right
that's a better way to do it so i was
like oh this is smart
like just [ __ ] i'm a curse [ __ ] it it's
way better than just breaking [ __ ]
yeah right so i've learned to express my
anger in other ways and now i don't even
do that now i'm just
not as angry i go just like my grandma
grandma taught me the mess
so he's looking down and you're so proud
he's like oh he's just like
oh that's my grandson he's like he rapha
too much but
it is
do you know about our history all asians
turn japanese
all asians are japanese when they go to
heaven
very very similar in cultures though but
yeah um have the conversations
don't don't uh don't not talk about the
stuff because i think you have to put
everything that you got on the table
because at that point it's like if you
can't be honest with each other then
what
what's the point yeah communication is
key always and you have really
friendships too anything you got to be
able to talk about [ __ ] if you can't
talk about something with somebody it's
already we're not like [ __ ] patricio
up here just having mindless sex
yeah this guy's good you know
the very few experiences that i've had
in my life women have been like
like very forward with me i get really
uncomfortable and i don't like it
especially if i don't know them like
if if they're coming up to me and
they're they're being very forward
what's up with you egg bro i'll be like
what's up with you babe
what's up with you baby looking all
crispy and [ __ ] like that you ever [ __ ]
with a woman like me i really
like that homie what's up you're trying
to [ __ ] this or what i'll be like how
you're crazy and i'll go i would love
my marker oh wow and you ain't never
seen crazy yet until i [ __ ] suck that
dick and make you come in my [ __ ] ear
hole you feel me
and i'm like i don't know
when i went to that phase of just trying
to hook up with people it doesn't feel
what was it like for you hooking up with
girls like that
it didn't feel good no it was like it
was good in the moment just because i
was going through a dry spell and i was
like you know what dude
i just want to [ __ ] and then after we
[ __ ] it was like
hmm i could have just jacked off that's
right that's what it felt like
it is it is kind of like a drug in the
sense where you need to like just get
that fix
um if you're just yeah like i i mean
being in a relationship with someone
that you like really get along with and
like connect with is way better because
sure because like
it's like having a homie it's like
having like friends that are like you
know
a lot a thousand people but you're just
acquaintances with everybody versus if
you have three like just really solid
[ __ ] friends the three solid friends
all day is what's what's up
so i'm trying to say have three [ __ ]
on the side
have a rotation no no no no no no
patrick's but the thing is is like that
that deeper connection is really what
it's about but that being said
i have gone through the same thing too
where like you hook up with girls and
you're like
at the end you just kind of feel like
grow like what am i doing this is what
all i'm doing like i'm just looking up
and it's just like you look over and
like
like what the who is this yeah you just
leave my house feel that great but
sometimes you hook up with somebody and
they're like pretty cool and you're like
this is just great
yeah you [ __ ] you [ __ ] walk chaser
yeah dude
bro sometimes it's like like this guy
gets whopping honestly
like one specific this girl hit me up i
was at my friend's house
she hit me up and she was like can we
[ __ ] right now like i'll just come over
to like i just want to i've
never had anybody say that and i was
like i was at my friend's house i looked
at the text i laughed and i
looked at my friend i was like i gotta
go
i was like i got an emergency right now
and i went home
laughing we had sex she left and it was
like and i just went back to my friend's
house i was like
wow that was great about that i've never
had like those situations
i've never had a girl look at me and be
like you are somebody that i want
to see naked yeah i want to sit on your
face let's get out i would love to see
that [ __ ]
i i have this one homie like he's when
you look at him he looks like somebody
who's
i mean he's a sexual dude right but he
looks like somebody who's like that guy
that spits like mad game
yeah he's not he's actually very
socially awkward when it comes to women
but he looks like a sexy dark mysterious
ass dude
and kind of like the job that he does
it's very sexy
it's super sexy what's his job you can't
say but he's a very sexy it's a very
sexy type of joke sexy job
like what's an example of a sexy job
that's not what he does catering
so [ __ ] yeah i want to [ __ ] caterers all
the time all the time dude
jewish caterer dude matzo ball soup and
then [ __ ] brisket baby
this is before he was married he sent me
this uh texas when he was like trying to
[ __ ] around a little bit
he would put up his profile picture very
handsome dude just tatted up
nice tans i gotta get some tats dude get
some tags
you would look a little weird you're
like you're trying to wear it relax yeah
relax man i would take it away you
should get the zebra gum tats and then
tat over there oh yeah
like to the train and then tracy yeah
that was pretty new i can make a dance
and just do that
i love it so he said he showed he showed
me one of his [ __ ]
yeah shut the [ __ ] up so he showed me
this one uh
tinder conversation right and i'm
talking about a dude that doesn't have
to do any [ __ ] work for women is
this guy she literally wrote where are
you
at right and he goes and just he was a
little drunk at this time and he goes
like oh i'm at the i'm at my house blah
blah blah
and she goes okay she's like i want to
[ __ ] you are you trying to [ __ ] right
now he goes
will you let me come in your mouth she
goes you could literally come wherever
you want
wow right and then this is this she
called his bluff
right because he doesn't really talk
like that and he just goes tight
that's all he wrote he wrote tight and
then he texted me what do i do i was
like bro
it's done in her mind she's like saying
this
because you played it cool he played it
cool he wrote tight did he hook up with
this girl
no because he he was too busy talking to
me about what he should do i'm like
you don't have to do anything literally
through your address
just send your address that's it that's
where are you location
nothing but that's happened to him
multiple times he has like this mystery
and they think it's mysterious like
this is awkward so he's so i can't put
my finger on it's like because he's
socially awkward he's just [ __ ] weird
he's scared of you
dude there are guys like that like that
i had homies who like that were like
that that
were good looking girls liked him like
he's cute and they would start talking
to him and then they'd like oh this
guy's kind of [ __ ] weird
i would just be like bro just chill out
a little bit like like they just
somebody's just turned into complete
weirdos where it's just like they're
like dude i'm over here i'm like i got
card tricks and [ __ ] i'm like hey you
guys
pick up pick a number pick any number
then i started bringing a [ __ ] scarf
out of my luggage
let me show you something we got a
couple of buddies like that that just
were just like you know just a little
stranger
like good looking no not like they just
get girls
thrown at him all the time oh you don't
have to do anything yeah one of our
friends
who's a very good friend of mine he's
he's going to be the best man at my
wedding
this dude just gets you know
he gets stuff thrown at him all the time
he's a handsome dude he's a handsome
dude like he gets like
one time i'll just say this this one
person who was in a relationship
messaged him and said you know who
you're talking about he goes she goes
you know like i i can't can you just not
talk to me anymore
because i'm like getting really
attracted to you and i just can't do it
i have
never had anybody say that to me in my
[ __ ] life and
i know like i know this dude like the
back of my hand and he's like he goes
dude i wasn't doing anything
like i wasn't even trying to i i didn't
do that that's like the number
one charmer dude thing to say yeah i
didn't do
that any snake charmer over here yeah
yeah
so i slept with them instead and it was
great what is that like i wonder what
it's like for guys like that where they
just
to dunk they just [ __ ] they live a
hot girl life that's what it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is exist
lucky like that like super super lucky
not me dude i've had
i'm trial and error honestly when i
first started talking to girls on aim
i would say you are the most beautiful
girl i've ever seen in my whole life i
bet you all guys want to be with you i
said all that
lame [ __ ] too and then i realized like
oh no one's [ __ ] me so i just gotta
ignore them
it's like you're pretty for a five oh
oh bad about yourself i ain't a five
i'm at least a seven or eight i was like
yeah maybe in the ugly ass city you from
she's like [ __ ] you i was like yeah you
trying to [ __ ] and she's like
i got that from that dating expert you
gotta just you gotta [ __ ] let them
know that they're special but that ain't
too special
yeah yeah you have to play cool you just
have to be your own dude you know if
you're too thirsty
for it it's just it's it's wacky that's
how i got mad
same [ __ ] girl what's up girl
you [ __ ] beautiful for an ugly
she was like i [ __ ] hate you don't
ever talk to me again yeah what if i
can't even speak i'm a mute
and she was like say something i said
he called your bluff she's
how was he talking and then how did he
go mute in a second it makes no sense
i was like i was talking to you on your
mind baby bam
telekinesis good dude yeah i've never
had a woman ever approach me like that
in my [ __ ] life
even when i was like famous on youtube i
still had to work for it
i'm like you know who i am but like yeah
no
you know exactly who you are like you're
funny i guess yeah i know it's my
favorite
i don't know people i guess but really i
mean come on can you hook me up with joe
jutsukawa that's it
i was like i can i really can
amen well guys that wraps up this
episode of the jesus braid podcast
amazing episode by the way the best
this is the best the best yeah i love it
they say your questions y'all
yeah i like the questions bro keep
sending the questions are good yeah they
happen every time
they just people just hit me up with
their life problems i personally like it
yeah let's do it it's great
yeah you get a lot of different
perspectives perspectives yeah this full
what's happening stroke
yeah usually yeah usually actually
around 9 30 every night the conversation
got really well you have a stroke bro
yeah about three times a day yeah what
about you guys none
no no no strokes at all wow no
yep well guys hell yeah where can they
find you
nick the ear on anything
and patchy.riley on instagram
and there you guys go find your boys all
places everywhere nick is a professional
trainer of some sort
yeah what is that what is your title
again like a professional i teach
juggling at the park so like if you uh
like don't make fun of that guy that
juggles there every day man come on no i
wasn't
you were that guy is good i was
literally like you're making fun of me i
was not making fun of making fun of the
juggler
i praise him that guy he's juggling he's
he's good
dude he he was today he was doing balls
and then pins as well ooh
pins as well but that looks like i'm
telling you that guy is there every
single [ __ ] day and he does it for
like two three hours he's
he's legit that's dedication when you
know there's a master is when you see
pins
i think i think he's a professional into
a bowling alley and stole these to do
this
where did you get those you actually
can't buy these
yeah the new ocean's 11 plot to get
these
from a goddamn bowling alley
i will say this for some reason i
[ __ ] hate magicians
and i will see you guys let's get one on
and
just like you should get you should
interview me
it's just obnoxious it's a little bit
because like every time we're having a
conversation there's a magician there
he can't wait to show us his magic you
know what that is the guy that
the magicians are equivalent to the guys
that bring like guitars to parties
yes that's what it is it's like yo we're
chilling and he goes like hey
can i show you something i'm like abso
[ __ ] lutely not it's
like it's like it's like the guy that
knows he's good at dancing and he just
dances everywhere
like or he does like yeah like backflip
like he does [ __ ] i was at the gym i was
in the sauna
and this guy's talking to me about doing
bachata and he's like sometimes when
you're doing bachata
and you're just feeling it with a girl
and there's like other dudes like in the
and he's talking just to me direct eye
contact he's like you just move with the
rhythm of the dance and i was like
what the [ __ ] you're just looking up in
the sauna like there's
his dick
he's like i met good people in there
it's great i was like
my name is like these other guys do you
see these in the magic castle
i wanna go i've never been let me tell
you something i've never wanted to beat
up everybody in one place in my life
they're all
they're all virgins or something i mean
the shows are really great but there's
just a bunch of random magicians there
and they're standing they stand there
and they wait for you to approach them
and they so you have you walk up and i
have to entertain it it's such a it's
being a magician is such like a weird
pretense it's cool if i think if i'm a
kid
like if i'm if i'm a young kid and i
want to be amazed by [ __ ] that's not
real
i would i'll say this the only time i'll
watch magic is watching other people
react to magic
yeah that's cool the only time like like
that's the only time i'll watch it
otherwise i couldn't be bothered dude
there was a magician guy that got upset
at me
because i wasn't amazed at his tricks
and i told him so you're doubling down
and i told him i was mad
he was upset but i told him i didn't
want to see his magic tricks like i
wasn't
i wasn't in the mood [ __ ] out of here
this guy he was showing me this magic
trick
it was a [ __ ] where you uh where he
takes the number that you're guessing
and then i whatever what not right and
he does it and he was like
he smiled at me and i was like all right
man
eddie was like you're a [ __ ] dick and
i looked at him i was like oh i'm a dick
i didn't approach you yeah i didn't ask
to [ __ ] look at i was not a
participant in this [ __ ] yeah
you wanted me to be amazing i don't like
it
he magic raped you dude that's a magical
rape i do not consent
yeah and i told him i'm trying to go to
the store man i don't want to see your
[ __ ] magic because the other thing
about magic too
it's like you know that there's some
[ __ ] of all
involved yeah of course like you know
you're not like
once i figure out what you're doing
you're like okay cool you leave
that's why that when you ask like well
how do you do that
as soon as they tell you how you how
they did it you'd be like oh yeah all
right
reveals his tricks yeah because you
would think that oh this is lame it's
like watching the avengers and it's like
oh how do they film i saw this
because they think it's iron man real
it's like no it's cgi if they do magic
[ __ ] like david blaine right
where he's talking out of nowhere and
you know in his monotone [ __ ] you
know
pedal voice he's like have you ever seen
me before yeah it's like no i haven't
seen madden floyd
like rocky is that you that's crazy
and all of a sudden david blaine burps
and then a [ __ ] bullfrog comes out
his mouth
yeah i'm down with that [ __ ] yeah yeah
i'm like whoa what's the [ __ ] dude he's
like check us out you want to see me
hold my breath for seven days check this
out and you're like oh [ __ ]
guys you see that one he actually died
so yeah
i remember there was one that was like
chris angel right and he was laying on
the concrete
and they're like we're going to use a uh
i guess a steamroller
to roll over them and they're like oh my
god how did he do it
and all he was doing was he put a
tempurpedic mattress
so when the [ __ ] the when the the uh
bulldozer ran over him he got it looks
like he got smashed by it
and he pops up and he's like ah see but
it's like it's not
magic dude he put a tempur-pedic
mattress on his back so yeah he was
laying on a temperature
tempur-pedic mattress so when the
steamroller went over him
like you're like oh my god he's getting
killed but he survived how did he do
it by the way if you do magic i'm not
knocking on you yeah i'm just saying
that i i
i am allowed not to be amazed like i by
it
and also don't force your tricks on
anybody that's magic great but that's
that's magic right now it is unique
you need magic consent before you
perform i do want i do want [ __ ] if i
say i don't care
right and then you keep pressuring me
like yo just you'll love this just wait
it's like
what are you doing yeah bro like being a
molester if i was a magician i'd be like
okay cool later
you know because like for you to like
give your like to yeah it's
awesome it's just me and you like just
two dudes in a room
i'm like can i show you something that's
already like
red no red flag like you've already
[ __ ] this whole dynamic up like
i'm looking at you weirdly i'm raising
an eyebrow
[ __ ] away from me yeah yeah you're gonna
pull your dick out what's going on it's
a weird pretext
it's a weird pretense
yeah can i show you something is it
magic dude it's my dick
perfect go ahead pull it up pull it out
you're gonna saw it in half yeah let's
see
seconds five seconds i want you to split
your penis in half and then pee in two
bowls
magic well guys episode of the jesus
brain podcast and we will see you
next time thursdays and sundays baby
peace